hello guys my name is ash Ono and
welcome to episode 6 of my lot of dare
series where we take a look at Genesis
my first little video game and we see
what's wrong with it and we just go
through and basically do a full code
review and fix all the bugs and stuff
like that anyway last time we basically
handled mob lighting and we actually did
fix it
so we made it hmm so that I think the
time is yeah pretty fast here
so like mobs actually properly one day
approached the light they get lit up and
there's no bug with that anymore which
is nice we found some really really
weird code that I had written right
anyway we found some really really weird
code last time that we fixed for this
time which was nice but yeah I mean
overall it was pretty it was pretty good
episode of thought and so if you haven't
checked it out you're gonna want to go
back and check out episode 5 because
it's it's pretty good
ok now we're going to talk about what I
said we will move on to next which is
more or less the mechanics of the game
and we'll kind of I don't think we've
pretty much covered everything there is
to cover in terms of graphics so we've
got all of our screen stuff we've got
the I mean this is kind of yeah that the
map doesn't the map is like the mini-map
thing that isn't actually in the game
we've covered how levels get rendered
and all that stuff we haven't covered
how menus get rendered and stuff like
that I don't think that's too important
one thing I will quickly cover before we
get into the rest of the game there was
this main menu because as you can see
the main menu including like help and
about and stuff like that this actual
menu system is kind of how's the game in
the background right so how does that
work
well the way that that works and I
actually have no idea so I'm about to
find out but the way that that works is
assuming we have some kind of yeah so
the way that we the way that we kind of
work this out is the main class or the
game class which is the main class right
it has a few public static kind of
fields right so there's one for menu and
so what happens is when we start the the
main the when we start the game we
create a new main menu and so we assign
that to the menu instance right and
because we do that
you know menu isn't null and thus the
menu gets actually rendered ok that's
why we actually see
these you know Genesis and play help out
and all that stuff if I was to not not
ever create that menu right we wouldn't
actually ever see any tax we see it
wasn't we with societal level but we
wouldn't be able to as you can see hit
spacebar to play the game or anything
like that because the menu is not okay
now apart from being rendered the menu
also gets updated if it's not null and
that happens in the update method so
it's pretty easy it's not really like a
lot of people asking me hey how do you
do game states right like menu state a
game state you know any other states
that you might have in your game how do
you create like a state machine to deal
with them and this game doesn't actually
really have a so called state machine I
mean it does in the sense that you know
the state is hey is there a menu right
but there are also different states such
as this is this is terrible code by the
way so don't look at that but in terms
of that like you know level gets updated
all right what is the level that gets
updated well that will change like for
example if the biome selection says I
want level two then level two will get
created and then of course next time it
comes around and does level two update
level two is the one that gets updated
so rather than having especially four
levels rather than having like a state
machine being like hey I'm I'm in the
game state therefore I need to be
rendering a level right now in this case
in this sense at least four levels it's
constantly rendering some kind of level
and updating some kind of level because
even the menus have a level right
because this is a level right and in
fact there's a function that I noticed
out of the corner of my eye
earlier that's called set menu level and
if we look at that what that actually
does is plays the the menu theme like
the sound the music it creates this test
of PNG level right assess the player to
be player input and then adds a bunch of
so hold menu mobs and menu mobiles are
just mobs that have a certain behavior
and a certain sprite yeah that's it
that's just the type of mob really
there's nothing really too special about
those menu arms I am actually curious as
to why the player gets created because
I'm assuming that doesn't actually need
to happen if we were to launch this
so we're gonna crash isn't it yeah all
okay cuz the play has a location and
that's how we set the camera so just
instead of having to like rewrite that
mechanic I guess to position again
because the cameras directly there is no
a camera right the camera is the players
current position so if there's no player
then we don't really have a camera
that's why I did that I guess but I'm
curious as to what blocks the player
from actually moving the camera I'm
assuming that's the fact that the player
isn't updated or something so what does
player up that actually happened because
it doesn't happen here okay I guess it's
a I guess the player gets added into the
level right where's the player here's a
player doesn't look like it oops player
okay yeah no it does look the I'll bet
hang on oh I see why that's interesting
okay so the reason the player can't move
is because the player doesn't actually
get added to the level you can see it
gets created here which means that its
position on the screen can be used to
determine the X crawl on the Y scroll
which is basically the cameras location
so we do that
however since we don't add the player
into the level the player never gets
rendered or updated because the level of
course is in charge of calling the
update and random method for issue of
its mobs right or each of its entities
the fact that the player doesn't exist
in that list because it never gets added
means that that entity that player
doesn't get updated at all so it's just
literally the player only gets created
for the sake of having an X and y value
that's it and that's all we do that we
read from that X&Y value judgment where
it is my voice sounds a bit high or
something it's because I've been like
singing all day and so I'm kind of a bit
higher pitched than I would be if I
wasn't so just thought I'd mention that
because I do actually I can hear myself
and I sound like I don't know half an
octave higher than I usually do anyway
that aside
okay cool so we have that that's how the
player gets used to actually determine
the level and everything like that and
Deming where to position the counter for
the manual but that's that's but that's
about it I mean it's just like any other
level okay the fact that we get
texturing over top of it and we actually
get the our keys to work yes this
episode in case you haven't noticed is
going to turn into how menus work
because I actually it's interesting but
I get asked all the time how to create
menus right as if it's just like some
complicated thing I mean I my opinion
about that is that it's easy and
everyone knows that it's easy to create
a menu but there's just so many
different ways to do it that perhaps
like determining the correct way to
create a menu is actually something
that's a bit difficult I mean like there
is no real correct way that there are
there are bad ways and there are better
ways but there's no like this is how you
should make every menu ever because that
that doesn't exist right this is
computer science there's a billion
different ways to do the same thing some
of them of course gonna be inferior some
are gonna be superior some are gonna be
kind of really really really really good
for like this but bad for this and
that's why you have to kind of know a
lot of different ways I guess to make
menus for example because you know you
didn't pick the one that fits your your
use case and your requirements basically
I'm gonna drink some water but uh yeah
menus pretty cool huh sir mmm I remember
when I made my first menu probably for
this game actually I didn't think I made
menus before that maybe for 3d gamberoni
maybe well maybe for that game I made
when I was like 12 or 11 actually anyway
um let's talk about that because that's
a different topic topic for another
video so mmm menus so menus this is
packaged here called menu folder called
menu we have this is how I like to make
menus I make a site a superclass called
menu this is basically like a base class
usually abstract it doesn't really
particularly matter if I mark it as
abstract or not as long as I don't
actually you know use this kind of I
don't think
constructions actually used anywhere
apart from in soft classes so really
like if I made that protected I'm sure
that it wouldn't actually care like I
shouldn't get any errors yeah I don't
write because men use never constructed
you never make a menu you make a type of
menu so abstract is probably better
description right anyway the point is we
have this menu there's two ways to make
a mini artisan on construction I miss
that okay see nothing good we have on
takes an input handle of some reason
want to taste an in-game object which is
even bigger than an input handler I
don't know why we specifically pass an
input handler here because I'm pretty
sure that I remember a static in public
it is no need to pass that through but
we do anyway whatever we've got a random
we've got a game object that we still
own potentially an input object in one
of these is going to be null obviously
depending on which constructor we use
but the main thing that we have in our
menu class is an update in a render
function and those that's kind of the
flow for any any kind of anything that
is interact like anything that you
interact with or that has the capacity
to change over time
has to have an object method right so up
through it so for interaction right we
need to be able to check keyboard input
and stuff like that we need to have an
update method to be able to do that and
by have it like changing over time and
stuff like animation or you know it's
something that basically has the
capacity to change at all needs to have
an update function okay some people
choose to like in the scope I don't want
this video to become like a a
programming guide but like I know that
you know the we're a job we're using
Java right now we're using an
object-oriented programming language so
I like to you know object-oriented
programming languages I like to take
advantage of the fact that we are
dealing with an or P language right what
I mean by that what I mean by that is
you know we have this object you can see
I've got this menu hierarchy and what I
essentially have is I like you know
everything to do with menu everything to
do with menu should be in the menu glass
right like it's very easy to just create
a class that is just a data only struct
and then implement all the functionality
of a menu
inside the game class for example you
can do that right that's basically a
procedural approach to kind of
programming because you're just treating
this as a struct essentially like a
struct in C right so no methods nothing
like that like a struct in the C and
then basically implementing everything
in like a function that is in a
different class right it's nothing to do
with it really okay the fact that we're
in an object under language means we
should be grouping stuff like that in
methods that are in the class so all
functionality to do with menus should be
in the menu class makes sense right the
reason I'm saying this and this is
probably really obvious for a lot of you
but some of you some some people I know
because I shoot at people privately I
know they like they don't date they
don't do this right they struggle with
this and I'm also saying my approach is
correct what I'm saying if you're using
an object-oriented language this that's
what in my opinion that is the correct
way to program in an object relative
language right that's why object objects
exists exist objects are essentially
data plus functionality okay and they
should be relative to that or relevant
to that object so you'll see that I and
also I'm also basically taking advantage
of virtual methods here because what I'm
doing is I'm saying and and like
inheritance and polymorphism
specifically here because what I'm doing
is I'm saying I have a menu object now
the concrete type of this menu object is
up to the assignment right so in this
case for example we assign a main menu
okay if the main menu the main menu is a
type of menu right so I'm using
polymorphism here because I'm saying
that this menu can essentially be of
many forms one of which is a main menu
main menu overrides the update function
so I'm using virtual functions here
virtual methods and I'm saying that this
is the functionality this is this is all
of the the entire functionality of what
a main menu does and this is everything
to do with what the main menu should
visually represent on the screen okay
very simple we have a menu we have any
fields that we might have that are
specific to a main menu right anything
that's common across all menus goes into
the menu superclass but everything here
is kind of
to the mat the main menu class we have
update for interaction and changing
things over time right excuse me
and then we have render for everything
that needs to be presented visually and
that's kind of the structure of menus
right it's just like any other object
it's the same kind of thing of it's the
same we would be doing the same thing
for you know entities essentially like
all right we have all all of the kind of
things that change about an entity and
everything to do with interaction
happens in the update and then obviously
what the what the entity presents about
itself visually should be any entities
render method ok so we have all that
stuff here you can see that's how we get
that genesis on the screen I actually
render this from the text twice I render
a base layer of black right that's the
color black offset four pixels
vertically and horizontally to create a
drop shadow effect basically and then on
top of that I render a white text which
is why you get you know this drop shadow
effect if I if I were to you know
comment out the white you would see just
the drop shadow and then without the
drop shadow it would look like that
which kind of looks a bit like it's not
bad it's still readable but I quite like
that drop shadow and then the click to
focus you can see the click to focus
actually gets run it in the main class
I'm pretty sure yep so if the input to
focus is false then we have this thing
where basically for 418 or rather for
like the opposite of a tame it would be
32 for 32 out of like 50 cycles the text
click to focus in on the screen
and you can see that even if we're in a
snow level then we saw the call to black
because the I guess the rest of the
environment is white because it's snow
but yeah pretty cool so that's what we
get here obvious if I take that away
we're gonna gonna get the drop shadow in
this case
but anyway mmm that's how that works so
that's not actually part of the menu
that's actually part of the game because
obviously that happens even if I'm in
the game okay
so what else do we have here we have
yeah so let's talk about how the
interaction of the menu works and how we
how we switch between menus as well so
we have a time and this is actually
pretty terrible I'm not gonna lie
because at that point I don't think I
knew how to implement a key type 2
method pop properly so there was no way
for me to stop you know going down too
fast so I basically put a timer on
saying that every time you press a
button you have to wait at least 10
update ticks so that would be about 180
milliseconds or so you have to wait
about 180 milliseconds so it's 1/6 of a
second before you can actually go down
as well so that's that's enough for you
press and let go right
if you hold you can see you'll go up
okay
that's it that's what the time is for
because you can see that every one of
these input down events essentially
requires the time it'll be zero and if
the timer squared is zero we slowly
blade it down in the update and of
course the update one's 60 times per
second so that would be one sixth of a
second or about 18% of a second which is
why I said 180 milliseconds okay so we
have yeah so what we do when we go down
is we play the menu cycle sound the
default parameter just means later on we
loop it so for music of course we Lukas
it a true for the sound effects it's not
we reset the time is 10 so that doesn't
do again and then finally and of course
we limit how far we can go down and up
because we only have three options so we
make sure that they're selected which is
the index of the selected menu item
which the menu items are sort here yeah
we we essentially come which are doesn't
meant that it's still here anyway
because we set the text to that anyway
weird way of doing it but sure okay
so this should really be okay so we
actually changed that's the initial
value but we actually change it okay I
see so we really we reuse the same array
so yeah so we basically if if they're
selected this is just basically I'll
saying that if slicer item is set to
whatever it is set to if it's unselected
it's just called play for example if
it's selected right then and then this
can also be 0 doesn't matter but if it's
looking slight it has to be 0 in this
case anyway we basically surround the
selected item with these arrows which is
why you can tell what's selected now for
the help option if I press the spacebar
or the I think it's input excuse me I
think if the ads input use which could
be a number of things but I believe I
believe that we set that to space or
answer could be either this is also
really interesting way of doing input I
might go with that one I'm sad because I
don't do that anymore like I don't do it
this way anymore okay anyway so whether
the game menu yeah so you can see that
this is how we transition between menus
it's really really simple and it's not
particularly safe like I wouldn't do it
this way I think if I were in
coincidences I wouldn't do it particular
I wouldn't do it this way I think if I
do it again but basically the way that
we transition with my menus I mean let's
face well for example is we just we go
back to the game menu and we actually
set the menu to be the help to be now
help menu right so you can see that
there's a static menu and this is the
menu that gets rendered and updated so
we're just changing to put this into a
more technical way or technical context
we have a pointer to a menu class or a
reference to a menu class we basically
change where that pointer points to to
be a different menu which means that
next time it comes to update the menu of
course instead of running the render
function in one class it's a different
object which has a different like
virtual table so it looks up the other
function and basically we
we just we basically just switch where
how many points to that's that's it and
we make it point we construct a new menu
and when you have a point to the new
menu that's it I mean that's a very
that's kind of a an overly technical
description of how this works right we
just we switch out which menu we're
using okay um then we have the about
menu which basically have in the same
way right we play the pull up we play
the menu sound which is that menu
transition I guess sound we create an
about menu which you can see just as a
displays all this text basically and has
you know input up back which is escape
here it is if that gets pressed we go
back to the main menu we recreate the
main menu again and we of course switch
out the game's many reference to be now
to point now to a main menu instance and
that's it I mean it's really really easy
there's nothing to it it's not
particularly said the reason I said it's
not safe is because we changed the game
menu and then we keep doing all this
code like this this still runs basically
which is a bit weird because that made
that this reference gets lost now and
this object should get destroyed if this
was you know say four spots or something
this would kind of be the equivalent of
deleting game menu right and then
reassigning it which means that this
object now just got a trace from memory
which is bad because it means that when
we come down here and we're like okay
suddenly you know this is a surplus loss
for example and wherever here we delete
the game any object we reassign the main
of the game menu object we have to
return immediately because if we don't
we go down here and we're like we try to
read the value of selected but hey
selected is of course this das elated
and we just essentially deleted this so
that memory has been freed he might have
been already overwritten that could
potentially cause an a read access
violation and crash so that's not good
obviously this is Java so unless the
garbage collector decides to delete this
main menu object immediately then and
there which is never gonna happen
this is kind of acceptable but it's so
kind of not right I mean you can fix
that by just having returned but you
know by trashing our own ref
if you have to realize like this isn't
exactly reference counting so it's not
that dangerous because if this was
reference counting then by doing this we
would be deleting the instance of the
old instance which would actually result
in being the same as delayed this but by
doing something like this
we're basically deleting ourselves from
within ourselves so it is like writing
asleep there's no sense and delete this
is actually an acceptable thing to do
right I mean is like C++ it's acceptable
is is it's kind of like a go-to right a
go-to is something that you shouldn't
like do unless you know what you're
doing and in unfortunately a lot of
people always say stuff like don't have
a rather go to that's rubbish I hate it
when people say don't do this don't use
a language feature that was built into
the language like some fishes like go
twos require caution and require you to
actually know what you're doing and be
very very careful around that cuz yes
coders can be dangerous and they can
relate to bugs that you might not expect
but if you know what you're doing gotas
can be very powerful and they can be a
lot better than the alternative of
nesting like 15 break statements or if
loops or branching and select that it
can be faster as well a result in faster
instructions so that's what I'm saying
about this like delete this can be
useful as well but Jeff be careful about
what you're doing because I wouldn't do
it this way at all like essentially what
you need to do is if you do that is you
potentially run something like a I would
almost I would almost add a add
something to a queue that would be like
okay the menu has changed and that way
we have the safe completion of this
method and then before we run update
again or anything to do with this class
again we switch out the menu reference
safely in the game class and then we
never run into this problem of hey we're
modifying the existence of this class
whilst we're in a method in the middle
of a method in the class that we're
potentially deleting like I hope you
guys understand what the problem with
that is
again in Java it's okay because of
reasons right because the garbage
collector is lazy that's basically the
reason as I said like the only thing
that holds a reference to this object is
game menu and when we reassign game menu
to be about menu that's it our
references have been lost which means we
are in the to delete pile because you
can never run or reference anything in
this class ever again because we've lost
the only remaining reference to this
class yeah it's like if you do it's like
if you do let's see it's like if I was
to do new main menu right main menu only
exists for this one line I assume in the
constructor doesn't assign you know
something okay
you mean like over here main menu is
lost it's gone it's already gone you
can't do anything with it unless I
assign it to an instance RIA if I do
that then it's contained with an M and
then when M for example goes out of
scope which will be he'll that's it
nothing main menu there's nothing we
can't we can't retrieve it we've lost it
we've literally lost it's like if you
lose something yeah it's gone you can't
find it it's lost so that's kind of what
happens when we reassign the menu object
so it like in that sense it's a little
bit dodgy and I said in this series I
would talk about programming practices
and I would talk about what I did back
then and how I would not do this stuff
now and this is a great example of
something that might appear to be
somewhat innocent and if you logically
think about it yeah it kind of makes
sense
sure but actually there's a little bit
of a hidden kind of agenda behind this
not an agenda more or less a mistake or
an accident waiting to happen but again
since Java happens to be I don't know
how javis garbage collection was it
might recognize that hey I'm executing
instructions as a class that technically
doesn't have any references I guess I'll
finish the execution of this method
before I delete the object it might do
that I don't know how Java works
internally well I'm saying is that
that's not ideal and if you try to write
the same
code in C++ and of course assuming you
handle memory properly the proper
handling of memory in C++ with this
behavior would actually result in a
crash or potentially undefined behavior
hope you guys enjoy that little rant by
me cuz I'm pretty much gonna end the
episode around here if you want me to
talk more about this kind of stuff
because I mean I obviously like talking
about you know core technology and so
like that and also about the internals
of things and really getting low-level
into this stuff so if you guys enjoy
that you want to see him more that just
drop a comment saying I liked this
episode and also hit the like button
I mean I'll know that I should do more
of this stuff but I mean other than that
that's how menus work it's really simple
we just reassign references as to how
the start button works and we actually
start the game again it's horrific we
literally said game menu to null which
means that since it's null we haven't
we're no longer rendering or updating
anything so you can see over here for
example what we have menu doesn't equal
null so we only render menu if it's not
null obviously if we set menu to null
and we try to render and it will crash
with a null reference exception because
we're trying to look up a pointer that
is set to 0 which is not valid not about
memory address and then over here as
well an update we do the same thing so
with that many of null which is good
which means we're basically clear the
screen now we've still got the problem
of the fact that the level is set to be
the menu level which is over here yeah
right so the way that we deal with that
is because you can see we've set the
minion also what at a level what happens
to level little plays true whatever
don't care whether in fact what does
that even used for because I'm actually
a little bit scared that code that is
horrific so you can say that a lot a lot
of the way that I I do things is kind of
by
system of polling so to speak so I said
I set a value in memory this is almost
like what you would do if you were
multi-threading something because you
can't directly call methods you set a
value and then next time a method that
is in a loop runs again it reads the
value it's like okay this value is now
true therefore I can execute this code
once because I'm then setting the value
to false and that's actually how the
level selection works so again the
problem we had was okay we've set the
menu level so how do this level ever get
reassigned well if you notice here right
this is sneaky because you would expect
something like you know games I'll set
level two or something like that cry for
biome to know what it does is it sets
the play menu which is which was a
temporary manulis if we can bring that
up we should be able to I'm assuming
because that's actually a bit of an
easter egg because it's not actually
contained you know and again yeah so we
haven't select by arm and you can see we
can select something that we won't play
it doesn't really work probably but um
that was a menu that I guess I made one
gonna be so we have force notion Tagus
this desert doesn't actually exist and
then random would be a random slash my
guess but anyway um by doing something
like that
it says play menu by I'm I don't really
care about that at all
the important thing of what it does
though yeah so play Minotaur biome gets
it to or in other words it used to be a
random one between 0 and 2 so 0 1 or 2
which would be either a forest ocean or
snow or forest no an ocean I know what
the yeah forests no an ocean would have
been the order and that's it so you're
like well how does it actually start
well well
glad you asked because what happens is
we obviously return from this function
because that's the end of the update
function in the menu class so what does
that happen here right so what happens
is if we blah blah we updated a level
level is still the menu level at this
point and then what happens you can say
is it it checks it says is the play menu
is play menu table I am set to 2 well in
that case obviously he just got set to 2
by our main menu to play menu to biome
set to 2 because we've hit play so
that's true so it creates and
level it basically initializes the
entire level and then set the biome this
is this level thing to negative one
right so we we set it to two we create a
level then we started saying anyone
which means the next time because this
isn't a loop remember next time it comes
in Oh play menu item is negative one so
clearly it's not this if we didn't set
this last line ago that we keep creating
the level of number again that would be
bad so you can see that's how it works
so instead of calling a method once
which would be the like the reasonable
kind of logical way to do things we have
this card in a loop and we basically
continually check we continually branch
to see whether or not we should be in
the state of ideas created a level now
and that said Lost's for one iteration
one frame and then of course it says
like the menu biome to negative one
which means next time around
unless something sets it back to a value
above one or a value does either 0 1 or
2
we will not be creating the level again
ok so that's how the menu system works
I'm pretty sure answered everything you
would ever want to know about menus in
this sense it they're really simple read
through the code if you don't understand
it if you still think that I haven't
covered something about menus that you
are itching to know and you can't figure
it out on yourself or you just think
that I missed something crucial that I
should mention drop a comment below and
I'll dressed in the next video
apart from that next time I think when
we wanted to dress the game logic so how
entities actually work how the AI works
and I think what else is interesting
maybe stuff like collision detection I
don't know leave your thoughts Lea leave
a request as to what you want to see
next because I don't mind I'm doing this
for you guys obviously and this is
series is all about explaining things
that I wrote that you don't understand
and also obviously discussing like
programming kind of techniques and
practices as well so if you enjoyed this
video please hit like button follow me
on twitter they'll be link in
description below and honestly I'll see
you guys next time with episode 7
goodbye boom